in today's morning rounds the American
Heart Association says eating
healthfully is good for your
cardiovascular health but how about
trendy diets like keto and intermittent
fasting February is American Heart Month
and our doctor Tara Narula is here good
morning Tara thanks for being here thank
you let's start with a keto diet which
is low carb high fat very high fat is
that what does that affect potentially
how does that affect your heart
potentially so a lot of patients a
patients of mine ask about the keto diet
and it's very popular it's popular
primarily for weight loss and it can
induce a pretty rapid weight loss over
two to six months the issue is is it
sustainable and the problem is when
you're really limiting yourself to less
than 50 grams of carbs which is like one
slice of bread or one Apple we find that
over time it's really not for a lot of
people and when you look at one to two
years any effects that it has on either
weight or blood pressure or blood sugar
seem to be similar to other low-calorie
or low-fat diets and the other issues we
really don't have a lot of long-term
research to prove either the safety of
the keto diet or any sort of heart
benefits we were just looking at the
graphic seems to have some downsides
right so higher cholesterol exactly so
because you're eating 90% fat a lot of
people choose saturated fat so things
like coconut oil butter bacon red meat
and that can drive up your LDL which is
your bad cholesterol in addition you may
be depleted of things like magnesium or
selenium which is mineral and that can
be Pro arrhythmia in fact there was a
study this past fall that showed that
individuals who ate the keto diet it was
associated with increased risk of atrial
fibrillation which is an irregular heart
rhythm right and then because you're not
eating a lot of vegetables fruits and
lagoons you're really not getting those
antioxidants and the fiber that we know
is so what do you advise patients then
so I do have that sort of risk benefit
discussion with them and try to use that
well why are you doing this if it's
really just for a short-term kickstart
weight loss that might be okay but then
at that six-month mark you probably want
to transition to a more healthier
pattern of eating and something that's
sustainable that's always yeah the
intermittent the intermittent
intermittent fasting diet I know a lot
of people on it who swear by it really
like it vladimir duthiers
yes your dad also a cardio cardiologist
a lot of people do it and how does that
affect your heart so again the science
isn't there a lot of the studies have
been in animals and there really haven't
been long-term studies but what we know
is that it does seem to kind of reset
the body a little bit when you have that
time where you're not eating that
fasting period and that can allow the
body to kind of clear out toxins it can
regulate blood pressure and heart rate
and blood sugar and cholesterol and the
anti-inflammatory so there do seem to be
the potential for benefits or there new
hazards we don't really you know again
because I've ever really studied at
long-term but you're essentially
inducing a state of ketosis similar to
the keto diet because you're allowing
your body to break down fat did you know
certain times there's different types
right there's alternate day fasting
they're sort of fasting for time
restricted feeding where you eat only
for six or eight hours during the day
and then you don't eat that was your dad
also a cardiologist liking it he likes
it I couldn't do it it's very hard for
me to skip breakfast for example in the
morning but a lot of people really do
swear by it and on this Heart Month are
there some diets that you say are
excellent for your heart so plant-based
all of my cardiology colleagues seem to
be promoting your burger Tara that means
impossible burger beyond burger if there
are options alternate burgers yeah so
plant-based you know we've learned that
it's not just the vegetables and fruits
that may be healthier but when you eat
animal products your gut bacteria
actually create a by-product called TMAO
and that by product can be pro a
thorough sclerotic or formation of
plaque leading to heart disease
okay okay Mediterranean diet okay
you